one of these days I'll figure out the
volume control mm-hmm are y'all doing
today fine how are you all doing today
come on alright alright that's a little
better
my name is Spencer I'm here to talk to
you today about a little bit of my
growth over my career for the last 10
years this is a call this has really
this this talk is the culmination of a
lot of experience I think both good and
bad and I really appreciate you coming
to it especially a little bit past your
all's bedtime since usually we quit work
at 5:00 right so this talk was a real
labor of love so I appreciate you being
here and I hope you enjoy it as much as
I enjoy putting it together first things
first I always say this but before I
never the conversation doesn't end just
because I walk off the stage I'll be
here for the next couple of days you
have any questions about my experience
you can also find me on Twitter at night
and Bach where I tweeted out some links
to some parts of this talk which I think
are really cool this talk is really
about this company here it's called
rivet and what rivet is is a start-up
that focuses on building integration
software for the construction vertical
so this is the the talked about for the
last five years how rivet has come to be
from start to beginning and when I say
there were three rewrites there were
there really were three rewrites and
these are kind of what the rewrites
looks like it started off as a project
rewrite to a product to a
software-as-a-service to a platform as a
service and we are going to talk about
all of the steps in between but rivet
wasn't the only thing that was rewritten
there was also me again Spencer I I know
that sounds really corny I hope it
sounded just as corny as I thought it
did that I was rewritten as much as the
software was but this is really about a
very personal story about my journey so
far
and this is just the beginning right but
you know I've I've been here at NDC Oslo
for the last few years and I didn't
always look this good with the nice blue
on green contrast before I was kind of
washed out a little washed up this is a
picture of me from a few years ago I
look a little different I think I'm 30
or 40 pounds heavier too and so I wanted
to talk about because
cuz this talk is just as much about
rivet as it is about myself I wanted to
talk about my humble beginnings as a
person who worked as a company that I
will call JC so I started at JC October
2009 and it really how I got the job was
kind of an accident I didn't start out
as a developer I started out as a
support person so I was the person who
was the person who called when the
printer broke or email wasn't working or
my computer died that was my favorite
one especially troubleshooting a
thousand miles away and I wish I could
say that I looked as cool as this you
know plug in Ethernet wires in and out
of switches and doing all that and when
in reality I look more like this this is
a real picture of me from college you'll
notice the the mustard I don't know what
that's doing therefore and I don't know
why this picture was taken but I found
it on my Facebook I thought it was
pretty funny kind of represented how I
looked I had to wear a headset as part
of my job after all and this was the
makeup of the IT department at JC so we
started out we had the IT manager the
developer who was a contractor with a
company the product that they had was
kind of in maintenance mode at the time
and then they had a support person well
they didn't really have a support person
they kind of had a support person they
had a support person that the person who
knew the most about computers in the
company who was one of the owners of the
company all right the president of the
company was taking help desk calls when
the IT manager wasn't available because
he was putting out fires everywhere for
the product or doing something special
you know doing something special that he
had to because he didn't have a program
for a certain business process we had
the owner doing our technical support
which is kind of a funny thing so one
day I got a call and he said hey Spencer
don't you know something about computers
and I said yeah I think so and and at
the time I had gotten a referral from
somebody who you know I didn't want to
disappoint and they said and they said
well you know they told me that you know
something about computers and I and I
said yeah and he said I'd like to offer
you this temporary job inventory and
computers and I said no and he said to
hold on a minute and he had a 10 10
question quiz for that he said no you
you you should take this job so I did so
I I did this small side job and
eventually
hired on full-time as their support
person I also did their social media for
a while that's another show and as a
support person I got to work with some
really exciting technologies I worked
with Windows XP a lot of the hundred and
fifty computers out in the field were
had all Windows XP and they had special
software to lock down internet or virus
protection whatnot I also had to
eventually learned Active Directory and
learned how to manage Windows Server
2003 and then of course my favorite one
of the boy this was just a moment in my
career learning about exchange 2003 how
many people started out as a support
person not a developer how many people
in the audience phew phew alright cool
there was a few of you so I came to find
out this was not a common thing to come
from this but I I Dover it--in I didn't
know anything about development at this
point and I did my best to learn as much
as I could I thought I was gonna be a
Microsoft Certified Professional and
pass all the exams and and do all that
cool things all those cool things and I
was just learning as much as they could
about Active Directory and servers and
Exchange Management
things that I wouldn't want to do
anymore and one day I asked my boss who
was the IT director I said hey I have a
question
this development stuff I you know I see
Keith doing it the keys as a guy the
name of the contractor and I'm kind of
interested in doing that I took a class
on vb.net in college I got a c-plus in
it so how hard can it be right
and he's like looking and they like
think about the IT manager at that point
who's making that decision I was making
maybe 10 12 bucks an hour or something
like that the contractor was being paid
a hundred or something and he's looking
at that and he's thinking wow if I could
teach this guy how to develop I could
save hold off a lot of money so it was
pretty quick mm-hmm okay why not you
know what what harm is it gonna do you
know he's gonna if I fail then that's
fine I just go back to support if I
succeed then I do development and it's
awesome right so Barron died I found
some classes online and started taking
some class more classes on programming
and the product was built in vb.net and
you might think that well of course
naturally that would be your first
language but was it vb.net not actually
was it it was not vb.net it was a dotnet
shop was it
sharp no wasn't c-sharp wasn't even
something close was a JavaScript or HTML
or something no my first language was
sequel so I learned T sequel as my first
language so we signed up for classes and
I went to this class by a very good by a
very good gentleman I took there two
three sequel courses went through them
all and at the end of it I was like a
sequel master and I thought I was this
cool I was like fast I was moving fast I
was updating databases doing select
statements in reality looking back I was
more like this guy so my IT director at
the time said I've got some rules so I'm
gonna give you prod access because
everything shares the same system admin
password which is great practice I'm
sure and so we have some rules for
playing around in prod he really
instilled in me these rules like if
you're going to do something that's fine
don't delete anything unless you back it
up first
don't change anything unless you back it
up for us and don't even insert anything
and it was so bad that you know we had
the same we had it wasn't consistent
across tables but we had deleted flags
on everything and that was the preferred
way to do it of course that way that
made sense so this instilled in me this
huge data paranoia almost like make sure
everything was in order before I you
know commit transaction or do anything
like that this becomes important and as
Arnold Schwarzenegger said I'll be back
or I really just hold on to that thought
I'm gonna come back to that a little bit
I really influenced how rivet was built
so sequel sequel was my first language
well naturally it was a vb.net web forms
application how many people had done web
forms awesome awesome how many people
still do web forms I love asking this
question you know why because inevitably
people will kind of raise their hand
because they don't want to admit it and
they kind of turn away and they're just
like a little embarrassed but III still
occasionally do web forms just as part
of the job right web forms be p.net
thank god they had option strict on
right at least they had that so this was
kind of the network the kind of the
system of applications that we had we
had the asp net web forms application we
had a sequel server database and then we
had this account management software
written vb6
which thankfully i didn't have
to touch although I did have to touch
occasionally didn't have to touch it all
that much and it was a product that was
planned up being phased out at some
point anyways and then we had branch
batch processes on top of the database
how many people have worked on systems
like this this is really common this is
a really common architecture right think
this is just simple right and it's and
it worked it worked for that company
they weren't gonna grow much past this
so it works you know
so again I took those lessons that I'd
learned the first time I learned as much
as I could about C Active Directory and
Server 2003 and all that stuff and I
started reapplying that I started
reapplying that learning and started
reading and reading and reading I'm not
a morning person bye-bye typical I'm
just not typically a morning person and
I take just as long to get acclimated at
work so what I do is I go into work and
before I start tasks for the day I'd
fire up reddit I'd fire a packer news or
something and I'd read for 30 minutes
every day just get warmed up and then
I'd take the first task off my desk and
do it you know that's just the way I did
things and this really helped me so at
some point I became the support person
and the junior dev and and that worked
well for a while until they decided you
know what we really he's he's pumping
out code faster than the contractor is
right so that was good I'd kind of pro
quote unquote proven myself so I moved
on they actually cut ties with the
contracting company and I became the
developer the main developer on the
applications and at some point we hired
a support guy remember that face he'll
come in he'll come in a little later too
so we hired a support guy to take the
job so this was the new structure I was
making more money I was making a writing
a lot of code I was delivering lots of
value and in short I was doing this I
was making magic happen it was awesome I
was feeling really at the top of my game
I was what I call a get stuff done
engineer we call it something else my
work but for the sake of this audience
will say get stuff done right so I was
getting lots of stuff done I was writing
code quickly I was writing code actually
pretty decent quality too I was reading
not only about how to do certain things
in web forms but like code quality and I
had no mentor above me the the
contractor before me his idea of you
know being a senior developer and
writing good code was writing vb6 code
but just writing it in vb.net and he was
working on access apps too so it wasn't
doing me any good so I was really trying
to make up
for that that lack of mentorship by
learning as much as I could and I was
getting a lot of stuff done so one day
about one day a couple years before you
know the end of my my time there I've a
little story to tell
right so they came to me and they said
hey well it's a business right and
business is evolved our target market
really used their cell phones they
really use text messaging so they said
hey we have to change how we do things
we were doing things this way before we
were using email for the lot of our
marketing but we need to use texting and
they'll and this and and the way they
looked at me they looked at me and they
said well you've got to be the one to do
it and they were looking at me like this
this girl would look at me and just like
you don't have a choice you're the lead
developer at this time lead developer
whatever that means
so naturally we decided to add texting
to our application so we had to be able
to send and receive text messages using
a mobile phone or the web and we had to
have real-time push notifications if
somebody a salesperson got a text
message we needed to be able to route it
right to them but they couldn't use
their real cell phones there was some
turnover I mean there's a whole lot of
problems like we why we didn't want to
use the real cell phones right if they'd
taken a day off or they quit you know we
wanted to move those text messages on
preserve that history and do something
else and I was like well what am I
supposed to do like what am i I can't
just invent this out of nowhere and then
I came and I sat all I know why not you
know I've been doing years of reading at
this point I've been reading every
single day I've been perfecting my craft
or you know honing it at least not
perfecting it by far but honing my craft
day after day and at the time there was
an exciting new technology coming out
called zamarons and I read all about
xamarin and I had read all about lots of
other things that I ended up
implementing for this company I've
learned about xamarin and I was like
okay real time real time where have I
heard real time before oh that's right
I've heard of signal are so signal are
does real time it's a communication
thing so I can glue them together I
still didn't know exactly how that
architecture would look but put it all
together and it turned out pretty well
so with the requirements of this ware
that I had to be decoupled from the main
app for rapid iterative release releases
were a pain that's a different story but
I needed to be able to build it and
deploy it quickly so that I could you
know keep developing on my
and if the main app went down make sure
that it got the message later and then
of course we had to have the instant
push notifications to the employees the
text messages had to go to the employees
the employees had to respond send the
text immediately back that kind of thing
so I came up with a really you know
rough diagram right and I said okay the
customers phone somehow the customer
phone somehow text messages us and it
gets to our app back-end I'm skipping a
lot of steps in this picture right like
there's something in between they're not
sending text messages to us but it's
getting to our app back-end it's being
distributed out to all the sales folks
and it's going of course to our database
so I had read about this thing called a
message queue and I was like perfect
this seems appropriate like I could make
it so that the applications talk to each
other in HTTP on localhost that seemed
like a bad idea for some reason it
seemed like a bad idea I couldn't
articulate why it just did but I had
read enough about message queues to know
that this is probably a technology a
time that I was you know that that this
particular piece of this particular
thing could use used appropriately when
I really wanted and I was really kind of
digging the pub/sub model right like I
just went to if a text message comes in
broadcast that out we actually had a few
processes that listen for that message
and we didn't and at the time I couldn't
articulate it but I was like I can't
just make this thing like make HTTP
calls to all this things in order to
move the data around
it's got to be decoupled in some way now
I would never have said that then but I
can say it now I could finally put words
I found my words like a three-year-old I
found my words
I wanted to make sure it was decoupled
and so what I ended up doing was using
Twilio great product for text messaging
and then for the app back-end and the
sales app the the sales app and the
devices that were being used or the
sales app that was that was used for the
main telemarketing function I used
RabbitMQ and I said awesome I'll just
publish a text message received and you
know something downstream will handle it
the app back-end will do some logic and
that'll send it on to the sales app so
that way the message is moved
appropriate and it worked really well
and this is kind of how it looked right
it was kind of it was kind of coupled
together just you know functionally but
it wasn't actually coupled now this and
the deployment and all of that would I
had not what I had done then which I
thought was really cool
looking back today is I had accidentally
written the sort of micro-service so
that was kind of a cool realization that
maybe I knew what I was talked about
then maybe a little bit but a lot a lot
of times not and that was really one of
the lessons learned right so we're gonna
talk about retrospective lessons learned
it's really important to me learn
something new every day now at the time
I could articulate everything that I
learned new every day so this doesn't
necessarily go on sometimes you're just
gonna be do routine stuff so learn
something new every week but I'm you
know what I'm not gonna apply a time to
it it just is not something that like
just just be a consistent learner learn
every so often right it doesn't have to
be every day every week you know do
what's best for you right but learn
something try to keep learning try to
keep growing that was a big lesson two
big takeaway from me and this of course
was the was the architecture that we
were left with and which was good and of
course I was still reading I was still
learning so we applied a little bit of
angular and used that to kind of improve
the asp net webforms app and that worked
really well for awhile you'll notice
that that account management is kind of
faded away it's because we were phasing
out that product we moved a lot of that
product over to the web application
thank God I didn't want to do vb6 as
much as I I I'm sure some people loved
it but I was really loving dotnet and I
really I found it disjointed almost so
that was being phased out it was good
but then something that I really pushed
for the xamarin employee app that ended
up getting phased out too because they
were like well we can't make the
investment in mobile and all these
different things we're putting a lot of
weight on Spencer
in terms of like if he falls into a
sinkhole tomorrow like what are we gonna
do find somebody who knows
angular web forms Amer and say and they
said nobody's using it anyway so we're
gonna phase it out which was fine and so
the retrospective for again what fit
what didn't so let's say let's start
with the good I delivered a ton of
business value I was writing code
getting stuff done just as I said and it
was awesome but of course there be
dragons oh oh there it is there's the
dragon there be dragons right like
there's always good you got to take the
good with the bad got to take the bitter
with the sweets in my case this app was
fragile not just the xamarin app or the
angular app web forms it was all fragile
the whole situation the whole thing was
fragile
deployments were we'd often catch
problems later that we didn't know about
there was no good problem detection
right we we'd catch the problem
downstream and say suddenly they'd say
hey it's been three days and nobody's
received a text message that's a problem
right like when your text Munir business
relies mainly on texting that's a
problem deployments were still all
manual it I was all right click publish
which works for some people but it and
it worked and it worked for that
organization but it wasn't ideal because
I still had to manually do deployments
and there were no quality checks right
there was nothing building the thing to
run the tests but that didn't matter
anyways because there was no testing
there was no testing done we would do a
tiny bit of regression testing we'd test
the new functionality and off it was
shipped and we broke stuff all the time
I'm so embarrassed by this fact I'm
gonna make it a little bigger no testing
that really hurt us so when me and my
mate Andrew would do deployments this is
kind of what it looks like we we were
like a couple of crash-test dummies we
were just like gonna slam into the wall
and see what happened smartly our boss
said no deployments on any day after
Wednesday so on Thursday and Friday
Saturday we couldn't do deployments and
that was because Saturday was our main
day for business so that rule alone
probably saved me quite a few weekends
so that was good so Andrew bless his
heart he became a junior dev to who's
fallen in my footsteps he said this
development stuff is awesome I really
don't like support him to learn more
about developments and so this was the
structure of the company for about a
year this was a really fun time in my
career loved this and then one day I was
kind of itchy I was kind of looking for
a new thing and Andrew said hey I just
got an opportunity to my email that I
think you should look at so finally we
get to the rivet part of the story it's
part of the rewrites right so this was
me I was a good engineer I think I like
I said I delivered lots of business
value but I just still had so much to
learn I was getting stuff done but I was
getting stuff done at a cost a lot of
people have gone through this phase in
your career I gave this talk recently
and they said Spencer I related totally
with the get stuff done but at a cost
thing
because you know at the end of the day
we're still delivering value but we're
not delivering still as much value as we
could so as much as this talk is about
rewriting Rivet and talking about how it
got from a project to a platform as a
service we talked about rewriting me too
from this humble guy in college to
whatever that is to the guy right on the
very right side I had to rewrite myself
from being a get stuff done engineer to
being a senior engineer and being an
architect and on to who knows what so
again let's talk about story time quick
talk about what happened this is the
company this is a company called Goodell
net Goodell net owned the original
wholly owned the original what rivet
originally was and one day they got a
call from one of their biggest customers
and said hey we need to build this
integration between these two software
platforms they're like cool let's do it
we've got a job right like we've got a
suite of developers let's put them to
work right so essentially it just looked
like this like hey move data from system
a to system B keep them in sync pretty
simple right
well whatever they delivered worked
pretty well everybody was happy
and so they did their little happy dance
they were very and they were very
pleased until one day this guy's my CEO
said hey somebody said why don't we turn
this into a product this cannot be just
an uncommon project this cannot just be
an uncommon problem what's true about
the market let's see if there's a thing
for this and that's where we get to the
first rewrite project to product so we
needed to change it to something that
was built for somebody to something that
was built for many buddies and so what
we did was the engage they actually took
the code that was owned by the customer
they scrapped it and they took the
lessons learned from that and they
started over this was before my time
this was a few months before I joined
the company that they did this and this
is kind of what it looked like so sequel
server all builds on dotnet dotnet
framework at the time and it kind of
looked just like this when I got there
this is what they architected the guy
that architected this was a business
intelligence guy and I'm not surprised
by that let me describe so essentially
what would happen is we would take a
system we would take two systems we we'd
take that data from that system we'd
cache it in a local cache which is a
really smart idea really great and then
we'd all centralize it into a central
database kind of like a data warehouse
right it's like it's almost as if the
systems we build are the reflections of
ourselves this is the guy this is what
the guy knew so this is what the guy
built and it worked pretty well and then
we have you know if we want to connect
it with a system with a REST API we
still need to be able to connect it to a
system that's on-premise somewhere so we
had a connector app and the connector
app basically was installed on the
customer server and just did essentially
sequel queries against their database on
that low on that customer's drive and
then sent it over to us they send it
over to Rivet using rest endpoints and
then we had what was lovingly referred
to as a data process app it would wake
up and it was installed on our servers
it would take all the data that was
staged in those staging databases and
mash them together and then take any new
records for one system or another and
move them onto the target systems and
this was a console app like the the
connector app was also the same way they
were console apps that were controlled
by window scheduler whoo that's it was
great I guess it was fine it was a good
start so essentially it would kind of go
like this there would be a process that
would take the data from the system's
upload it to our system take the data
from the from our local cache put it in
the central database and then finally
we've moved the data from the central
database on to the system and the
on-prem system simple right
how many people have done integration
between any kind of system if you've
integrated yes of course we've all done
it how many times is integration like
simple unless it's like a product built
into an app if you're hand coding an
integration and trying to keep two
systems and saying would you describe it
as simple I wouldn't if it's too it's
too good to be true it probably is it
was too easy but it and it didn't work
very well let's break this down just a
tiny bit so we called this uploading
taking data from the system moving it
into a cache we would have one table per
model if it was an employee or a vendor
whatever it may be and we'd move the
data from that system into that cache
there's a lot of boilerplate involved
here whatever then we take the data from
the system cache move it onto the
central database like a data warehouse
and it was transferred via stored
procedure some duplicate detection but
limited and not very good and also a lot
of boilerplate involved in right
those transfers and then what we had
what was called downloading and we take
the data from the central database and
move it on to the system using their
REST API or insert statements whatever
we could do to talk to that target
system simple right
only if only so let's retrospect let's
talk about what happened in the first
rewrite I was there at the kind of in
the middle slash end of it they'd
already implemented that whole system
that I showed you that hold into that
whole platform they had already in
they'd already built it and so this is
what I inherited so good let's talk
start with the good so we had an early
beta customers to help us develop
requirements and we were delivering
value early our products worked and we
also another thing that was good about
this we were proving out the market we
found that people wanted to use this
integration so now we just had the
urgency to build was higher but of
course take the good at the bad take
bitter with the sweet we still got to
talk about the dragons
there's always dragons one of the
problems was lots of duplicates written
between databases as a person who was
paranoid about data this like kills my
heart to see we'll get back to that in a
minute
the state of downloaded objects objects
that were moved from our cache or the
central database on to the target system
very hard to track very problematic so
sometimes we'd end up duplicates
downstream and then it was hard to write
and maintain object connections moving
data from the REST API all the way to
our central cache it was easy it was
boilerplate but it was never as
complicated as just move this data to
here we had to deal with things like you
know we were transferring we were
creating tables out of them for gosh
sakes so we were making property names
but that doesn't all making properties
one-to-one at the columns from the Jason
but that doesn't always work because
Jason objects aren't always flat so lots
of things like that and then deployment
deployment was just as fun actually
way less fun than it wasn't my old job
but my old job was right-click published
at the new job it was this over and over
again how many people have had a company
experience where they that this is their
experience during doing deployments yeah
a significant share of us we know the
pain here it sucks
and then this thing the syncing
transferring the data between stored
procedures
I will come back to this another thing
so then we get into the second rewrite
this is the part but I really was like
kind of the chief of so I came in I was
freshly hired I was freshly hired and my
title was senior dev I don't know who
thought to gave me this give me this
title but I can tell you that I was
about as far from being a senior dev as
anybody else on the team there were
people on that team that were more
experienced than me that were junior
devs I had no idea I guess I interview
well whatever and I jumped right in and
this is kind of what it felt like I did
that value to a lot of projects I felt
like including rivet I was working on
rivet just very part-time there was a
couple of engineers they had a process
but jumped right in and finally figured
it out they this guy Tom or CEO said he
was still with us then he's still with
us now said hey I really would like you
to work on rivet you know let's put some
let's get you introduced and get you
familiar with the product at the time it
was known as app harmony not an
important detail took a while to get to
the rivet thing so app harmony so first
thing to fix there there were things
that I needed to fix come in and say
well senior developer Spencer surely you
know how to fix these problems right
okay tell you where I can tell you I
know exactly how to fix these problems
as much as I knew how to fix the
problems of my previous company I pulled
them out of somewhere you might not like
it hmm
so we had the imperfect development
model so moving the data around very
boilerplate very error-prone maintenance
of these things became a chore
maintenance of data we had constant data
breakages things that were duplicated
things that weren't showing up
we had to developer had to debug every
single step everything that everything
that had a problem a developer had to
intervene again this is the state of art
our current architecture let's talk
about the problems with this right so we
had the the connector app and what we
called the data process app they were
windows schedulers now they were windows
scheduler built console apps that woke
up and went back to sleep when they were
done now if we had a hundred customers
what are we supposed to do like oh yeah
in order to install this connector app
you have to unzip it you know it's in
the debug folder you have to unzip that
and then you have to set up a windows
task it
like oh my god if that were the kind of
that were I would I'd fire them right
away so like that wasn't gonna work so
they gave me a little honey-do list they
said these here's some things that we
really need you to do so we need to
convert these things to always on
Windows Services we had to improve the
deployment process we had to remove
obscure data bugs which is I could spend
at all I could spend a day talking about
that particular problem in general and
then we had to make development easier
and developers more productive right
they weren't things weren't happening
you know of course the people on top say
more more faster faster and that's fine
but you know find identify if in
efficiencies make them efficient and
they were like yeah you got this okay I
guess I got this so this was me on the
left this was me in the mirror thinking
about oh this is where I this is my
future state this is where I want to be
I got life goals I've got some life
goals that I want to achieve so honey-do
list let's start from the top convert
existing apps to always on Windows
services okay first let another lesson
here in my career reuse the stuff all
the stuff right don't try to be unique
some don't try to be creative sometimes
if you need to solve the problem and go
solve the problem and go remember this
thing this architecture that I described
this app back-end was actually built I
built a Windows service very easily
using a product called top shelf it's
very useful if you're building windows
services still it makes them really easy
to do and I was like cool I already know
how to build windows services so I'll
just a solve top shelf and off I'll go
right and it worked when all else fails
do what you know your goal is not to be
perfect your goal is to deliver software
your goal is to deliver value so that's
what I did I took the acknowledge that I
had taken in my previous company and I
just repeated it with a honey-do list
like that like those are all full-time
jobs I had to do something so I did what
I knew and it worked it worked pretty
well so this was improved this was
improved because now they were always on
not only were they always on they were
constantly well I'll show you we built
we took the connector service we got it
out of windows task scheduler I made an
always-on self updating Windows service
I'm shortening that to one sentence was
a lot harder than that
and we created infrastructure to receive
commands for it so that was signal our
that was back it was actually
backplanes for that for that
communication back to our home service
because we want to be able to push
commands to it we wanted it to push
commands back to our you know messages
back to us signal our was a pretty good
fit for that and then we wanted to take
the cloud service we'd lovingly called
it from data process to cloud service
sounds way more impressive especially on
sales calls took it out a windows task
scheduler made it always on always on
Windows service and then we built our
own scheduler so we said oh we need to
run this set of jobs so we'll build we
built a scheduler to actually run the
set of jobs that worked really well and
so we ended up with something that
looked a little bit more like this so we
had our system cache and our central
database still and now what was talking
to cloud service a lot of that was the
same but now we had something that we
could take the connector apps now talked
home now self updated so deployments
were less of a problem their deployments
internally we'll get to that in a second
then we had our API layer which
unfortunately and sometimes we still
live down these things that live down
the technical debt we take on the API
layer was also the front-end uh so that
was fine this was a pretty good this was
a pretty good next step and they were
very pleased with that I remember this
guy well this guy worked at my company
with me and he came on and guess what he
had just got done doing full-time pretty
much doing web forms they would you can
discard an angular so they were like we
need you to come in and improve the
portal he loved it he loves doing front
ends so he came in and he made our API
layer our management UI he really souped
it up and made it a lot nicer using
angular so he came in again we're the
product of our experiences and our
products of the product of our
experiences right so we just took what
he knew angular and went to town and
then of course we decoupled the the
management UI and cloud service
appropriately using RabbitMQ again reuse
the stuff you know and it worked well it
worked pretty well so we did that we did
this first root in our first rewrite or
a second rewrite we did exactly what we
said that we were gonna do convert
existing apps to always-on Windows
services done awesome so improve
deployment process could do a toll talk
just on that alone let me shorten it by
saying we used app fair fair was a big
value add for us it did a lot of the
work for us we already did a lot of
great work for us and it was awesome
so every time if you've used a player as
your DevOps Jenkins something whatever I
it's pretty much the same process every
time we push it up to source control
build the software run our tests and
deploy the software it's pretty great
but we were really only part of the way
there
we'd only really gotten part of our
vision implemented like we had a whole
you know down stream all the end-to-end
vision and we only implemented part of
it at this timeframe we had a long way
to go because of the way we wrote our
tests sometimes developers were writing
real tests sometimes they were just
putting ad hoc code inside of their test
project and they were just running it ad
hoc in order to manually test their
stuff okay fine so we didn't run the
tests automatically in that and and that
would have required a lot of work that
at the time we just didn't know
necessarily what we were doing so it
didn't do that and then technical
limitations then that we had to deploy
it all at once and stop services to do
it so we had to stop production and
deploy all at once
so monolithic in that way painful
deployments remember this thing that I
did that I was all proud about a minute
ago I did a great job that was one of
the things that suddenly made this these
technical limitations that was one of
the technical limitations I had improved
it by adding on limitations and of
course we all do this technical debt
isn't bad but it can be frustrating you
cannot I cannot tell you the frustration
that I felt when I realized the thing
that I had built which was a little more
admittedly at the time than we needed
the thing that I had built had actually
made the second step actually quite a
bit harder but software engineering is a
series of trade-offs there's never a
silver bullet right my goal was to do
this so I did this this is the first
thing I needed to do and then I needed
to improve the deployment process I
didn't say make it perfect
I said improve and of course getting to
what software development should be
ideally is iterative agile right that's
the true definition of agile do little
things at once at a time build up build
up your software so even though we'd
improve the first thing we'd improved
the second thing I'd made some choices
right that made the second thing a lot
harder but that's okay because our job
was to improve and we got our job done
so a fair huge value
for us at the time we're now moving to a
DevOps because they're tooling is just
way better but that's another show
oh this was a big one remove the excu
data bugs and make development easier
and developers more productive whoo all
right well
see what we can do so our main goal at
this point was we were moving data
between a cache database to our central
database so we did what any so this is
what we did is part of our development
process
let's take Salesforce in QuickBooks for
example just picking on them we would
have maybe a customer in a Salesforce
app and a QuickBooks customer you know
for a QuickBooks app and we'd create
separate databases for those things and
we'd cache the data there and we'd also
model the data as as it were we tried to
do basically a copy/paste right we
didn't want to be special and rename
things we just wanted to take it as it
was from the source system and cache it
locally so we do things like we'd have
customer name you know because a lot of
people when they've you know a lot of
times when you're building API api's or
whatever sometimes the thing was the
thing was a customer object and the
jason you'd get back was still customer
name all right that's fine some call a
customer name and then we had the create
date and then of course we had
QuickBooks where they didn't have a
create date just making this up as I go
you know bear with me but they had an
open date which was kind of the same
thing kind of wasn't whatever so they
had some they had similarities right
there they're never a perfect fit but
they're pretty close right in business
they're essentially the same thing so
the first thing we did to move data
between them this was before my time
they used sequel server integration
services
apparently we never talked about it I
never asked why because developers would
ball curl up into a ball and cry when I
asked him why did you move away from it
so I just kind of dropped that I don't
know why they moved away from this
apparently it wasn't good so that's fine
so then we were doing entity framework
they were spinning through they were
just for reaching over each of the for
each QuickBooks customer is it in the
Salesforce staging database no ok then
create a new record else update the
existing record or whatever or delete it
if you need to but this was really slow
and it was slow isn't it took a lot of
time in order to process all of that
data so they discarded it because they
wanted to move fast
they moved us stored procedures stored
procedures now developer I don't know
about you but I still suck at writing
sequel remember the sonic picture and
developers for some reason at our
organization just had a hard time
writing store procedures they looked
something like this right and they would
have special logic like if it exists you
know left join on the target table and
if the thing didn't exist put it in
there or update it right but sequel is
not a very friendly language as friendly
as the strongly typed language like C
sharp or vb.net because as soon as you
do this you have to do this for hundreds
of objects and thousands of properties
right this is thousands of properties
downstream as you took every object that
you needed to move and by the way don't
ever make a mistake now up to this point
we had data wasn't going in data was
going in too much it was duplicating
right so these were loaded with bugs
they just were so what they do they
called in the senior dev this was what I
wrote in on this is what I actually was
right just a dog in a wheel right so I
was just like oh okay
so I turned to my boss one day and I
said hey you know I'm I understand this
the source of the pain here I think we
can build something to effectively
describe how to move these objects
around and he said okay what do you have
in mind and I said I know about these
things called disc expressions right and
he said okay build me a prototype you
have one hour
what okay in 40 minutes I'd come back
with roughly something where I was like
okay here's the objects here's the
expressions that I use and I combined
them together using something like this
so I created a cert III would create at
this definition class essentially and
we'd use it to describe like okay the
customer name trimmed because working
with even legacy systems or sometimes
newer ones sometimes they loved to pad
spaces on the beginning or end I still
haven't figured out why they do that but
it's not desirable to see that in target
system so we want to trim them and then
we want to say well that's the
QuickBooks that's they take that trimmed
customer name and put it in the
QuickBooks name and then take that
create date oh by the way open date is
actually
is actually a required field so we need
that so take a create date if one's not
available because it's knowable in the
from Salesforce put in the current date
and time and put that into the open date
and so what we ended up was with is
creating these strongly typed
definitions to move data around so it
generated sequel that looked a little
bit like this right so we take the
insert statement and it would emit
really nice-looking sequel kind of like
how typescript you know pushes out some
JavaScript at the end that actually
reads pretty well that's what we would
admit and it worked pretty well so this
because we knew that it because it was
an expression because we were new we
were calling trim we know that we are
going el trim our trim on customer name
typo there should say customer name but
that's what it would Midd for sequel and
then for create date going to date time
now of course the null coalescing
operator translates roughly to the is
null in sequel so we'd say create date
if not we know to get used create the
get date function and sequel to move the
data around so this is essentially what
we were doing and remember that thing
that I said about paranoia I have to
thank my old boss for like driving and
drilling in this data paranoia inside of
me because it served me really well I
was so against bad date I was like we
are done with duplicate data problems we
were done with moving data but like data
not moving for it I really attacked the
duplicate data problems so under the
hood with these definitions I was able
to add logic to run them run this
statement make sure that the data moved
all up appropriately make sure that
there was no duplication if there was a
duplication stop the transaction
otherwise commit and suddenly many of
our data problems went away and it was
awesome what this did was made
developers way more productive and way
let it was they were writing out less
buggy code it wasn't perfect but they
weren't writing store procedures and
suddenly now we had a lot of data
protection and customer and the
developers were making data move even
better it was awesome so what fit what
did let's talk about it
so we vastly improved our platform we
vastly improved our deployment story
because we needed to scale right we
wanted to get to multiple
customers using this product so we had
to do some things and this is what we
had to do right we had to make the
connector out more deployable etc etc so
we made that we vastly improved our
platform and deployment was great
deployments were still painful they were
still painful but they were better so
we'll take that right software should be
edited or iterative right so the
development model was improved it still
wasn't perfect and we'll talk about why
in a little bit and this is a lesson
this is something that I believe
strongly in my heart
premature optimization is the root of
all evil uh I didn't prematurely
optimize I am a developer and somebody
told me once developers who are straight
you know developers that are just
c-sharp vb.net that's what they know
well they don't write sequel very well I
don't know if that's true for you it's
certainly true from HEA because these
statements ended up being scale problem
because they were slow and they were
emitting sequel that wasn't ideal so
without the help of a DBA to like you
know turn red and get angry and throw
things at you to like make you work
better to make you write sequel better
we were moving data but we weren't
moving at the most efficient way so we
had some problems with this as as we
grew so this was it this was the
architecture we ended up with and a lot
of time passed there was a lot of things
that happened I'm gonna skip a lot did
forgetting to the meat right a lot of
change has happened some of the changes
were good some of the changes were bad
some of the changes felt like this we
had customers that we would churn
customers we would churn partners
sometimes we would build an integration
it wouldn't work out sometimes we build
an integration it would work out really
well so we were doing a lot of things we
were experimenting and it worked pretty
well but sometimes it was painful right
but whatever we were still delivering
value can't criticize me because I tried
right so of course that's never how it
works and that's when goodell net also
spun it off into rivet and at that time
at some point I started my own software
consultancy and said to my company hey
you can be my first consultant or my
first client and they didn't really have
much of a choice because I built all the
other underlying systems what are you
gonna do
that worked pretty well for a while I
eventually spun this down and joined
them again which is a great move and I'm
very happy with that
and other lesson learned the central
database this data warehousing model
this very data warehousing esque model
didn't work too well right and the
reason it didn't work too well is that a
customer in one system a customer in
another system we were trying to boil it
down to one thing if there's one thing
about software that I said earlier one
size does not fit all what ended up
being happening was the central database
ended up being a lowest common
denominator for lots of things so we
threw it out and that was a really good
choice at the time talking a little bit
about the sequel right I made stored
procedures to these tight little
definitions that emitted sequel worked
really well for that model but at the
end it didn't work too well just from a
business perspective because it was set
based it was an object based like
individual record based it was set based
we were moving sets of data because we
were emitting sequel right so the DES
performance was pretty good we optimized
optimized got pretty good performance
out of it and we had a straightforward
development pattern great that was great
we loved these things we loved them for
a time but they poorly represented the
nuances of business workflows moving
data to data just wasn't it that's not
how business works right if you improve
approve an invoice in one system you
really need to tell the other system
that you approved the invoice and then
trigger some kind of workflow right and
our set based data model just moving an
object to an object didn't work so hot
for that it wasn't fast enough we had to
run every service in a certain sequence
and it took sometimes an hour sometimes
30 minutes sometimes 10 it really
depended on a lot of things volume of
data etc lots of customers were happy
with it
construction is the number two industry
but so far behind from a technology
perspective that's what our goal is is
to improve that so a lot of them were
just happy that we move data around but
some of them they get a taste of it they
get a taste of that poisonous Apple they
want a little more they want a little
more they start wanting real-time
development straightforward a little
cumbersome right it was better but there
was it still was basically an
abstraction on top of sequel had some
difficulties with it so it wasn't
perfect like I said real time they
wanted it right
now they were some people wanted that
data to move this thing to this thing
create a building so again retrospective
what happened what works well what
didn't well well let's start with the
good just because we had this old model
of the central database and we were like
we could have just continued to invest
in it and continue to you know use the
sunk cost fallacy we've already spent
this much money on it we just need to
keep spending because we didn't want we
don't want to feel like it was a waste
of money we didn't stick with it just
because we ended up throwing it out that
was a good decision and we had lots of
happy customers some that weren't no
totally happy you know that we're still
there were still problems with what we
were doing but we were making them happy
so we had customers we were growing that
was awesome but with the bidder comes
the sweet right we needed to be faster
we needed to be more customizable we
needed exception handling exception
handling better data exception handling
sequel sets of data through sequel
really poor way of dealing with nuance
and exceptions and data and data
integration it just is and developers
were built the platform they were still
responsible for putting out most of the
fires just a thing so at this point in
my career I was kind of right here I was
kind of like in this phase and the
senior dev to architect role right I was
having to think not only as a senior dev
but starting to think more like an
architect and we'll see that in a second
what fit and what didn't as I was
rewriting myself right first thing be a
multiplier that's the best thing that
you can do as a senior developer or a
leader either you have developers
answering to you or you're a team lead
whatever the case may be if you're a
senior developer multiplying yourself
and/or multiplying doing work to
multiply your developers should be your
number one priority and I learned that
you should scale people before you scale
software if you make them better
they'll make everything better right
it's it was awesome this was a good
example of scaling I made them more
productive by taking away a lot of pain
points out of them out of the
development process and that worked
really well there were other ways I'd
have regular meetings with them right
well we built developer tools right so
we built we built the developer tools
like the sequel omitting little BOTS
perfect we
establish patterns of reuse that was a
really strong one right I was just
saying here's the pattern implement the
pattern test the pattern like this and
you'll be successful
and that worked really well I give a
talk that I tweeted out a bunch of links
to a bunch of stuff that I referred to
in this slide that was this talk is all
about making a pattern for your company
and making it a specific pattern for
building api's for asp net core and a
really cool story somebody came up to me
at a conference that I went to and and
they said hey Spencer you know you gave
a talk here a year ago on this thing and
he said I turned around and I
implemented that pattern at my company
and all of our company 50-plus
developers use this pattern now and it
was really helped us a lot so we can
help him and it helped me it can
certainly help you
patterns are we use consistently okay is
in is better than being consistently
good it would be like it is better to us
stick with the established pattern if
it's good enough for that moment and
it's not causing you huge pain better to
do that than to be in consistently
better liked to just because you have a
project with 500 react components you
want to move to react hooks because it's
the new hotness
well there's problems with that right
you still have to tell your other
developers about it do you have to
refactor your old code right so it's
better to be I found and consistently
okay better than consistently good with
people it's important to compliment them
and compliment their strengths figure
out what their strengths are and give
them problems to help you figure those
problems out to help you help them help
you figure them out and then gently
gently help them recognize and
compensate for their weaknesses right
know what they're good at know what
they're not good at know what you're
good at and not good at really important
things regular one-on-ones helped a lot
I'd sit down and say let's pair program
we there's a company in my in Saint
Louis Missouri and that's where I'm from
the United States they do all pair
programming we found that doesn't work
for us so we do occasional pair
programming we found that works really
well and I'd sit and pair with a junior
sometimes I'd learn from them sometimes
they'd learn for me in the end we all
came out better and embrace imperfect
code especially if it's backed by tests
this is kind of a thing that I like if
it's stupid and it works might not be so
stupid i tweeted out once that i'll take
bad code backed by good tests any go
over good code any day and my friend
eric who is another as an architect as
well said well this is an interesting
philosophical question if the tests are
good how bad can the code really be you
have to think about that one
and finally for the second rewrite if
you're not embarrassed by the first
version of your product you've launched
too late this is the guy reid hoffman
who founded linkedin and we took this
and we really embraced it we were not
totally happy with our product but we
had customers we had money coming in and
that has made all the difference
so the third rewrite so we started it in
roughly really the end of 2017 2018
middle of 2018 full force and we're
still working on it today when will it
end we'll let you know right we really
took down we said okay we know what
we're good at we know the problems we
know the pain points let's focus on
making those better and try not to
compromise anything else in the process
not always possible right but still good
so at this point this was our
architecture at that time we had pretty
much the same thing as i described
before but we added in a customer UI and
we used did react with that one so we
took a lot of this stuff and we said
okay well there's still things that we
could do to improve it again
poorly representing the business
workflows that set-based data moving it
didn't work out too well for us we had
to scrap it it wasn't fast enough our
customers certainly not customizable
enough for our customers and the
development was straightforward still a
little cumbersome right because we still
it was still a lot of boilerplate we had
to new up a sequel database we had to
create models in entity framework with
those exact things it's a lot of
boilerplate and we found out that
especially when you do custom fields
that becomes really painful so we
started embracing schema lists we
started embracing schema embracing
schema list databases and we started
with cosmos DB as the first thing that
we did right the cool thing about cosmos
is that it's really easy to create a
data structure that is dynamic right so
we had a consistent data structure that
contained all the metadata that
and then we can put as much data as we
want into it it really simplified our
development process just getting the
data cache because we found that the
data cache again huge benefit our
application became more as we designed
it from the ground up to be more
decoupled at the old time at the with
the old application we had to deploy
everything at once
kind of like the crash test dummies that
I was showing you earlier we still live
some of that pain today right so we
wanted to decouple so we used Azure
services as your service bus
specifically to start moving individual
records individual data records around
as opposed to end and really signalling
that those data records had come in as
opposed to just moving it set by set
we've really embraced record based
processing this is kind of how it works
today it's very simple we wanted to keep
it simple because simplicity means it's
easy to understand and it has covered
pretty much all of our use cases for so
far right so a new record is added or
changed in the rivet Network or deleted
we trigger something for that record
some some process is listening for that
record to change if it changes BAM it
triggers another process to trigger a
workflow to move that data around right
and we can do a lot of cool things with
this we can do if a record if a status
of an invoice in one system has went
from open to approved now we can say oh
let's create a custom approved record
now will signal to any integration that
wants to listen for it will say that
this invoice was approved a system
downstream will say awesome got it now I
can approve the invoice in my system and
keep everything in sync so again going
back and impressing that pub/sub model
really worked out for us and this is
kind of what we've ended up with so
we've ended up with a really cloud back
notice that we try not to reinvent the
wheel as much as we could right you
can't beat them join them and you
certainly can't beat as your AWS those
kinds of services that are providing
really solid at cosmos DB the service
bus they provide really solid services
and it took away management of
infrastructure which we are not is so
good at and this is what we've ended up
with we've embraced react and dotnet
core as our schoo to standards and in
this way we've really built out a
platform to allow people to build
services on top of our system and in
that way
that's how we went from being a
software-as-a-service where we just said
here's the integration data to a
platform as-a-service
we have this integration data component
but with this this integration component
that we can build for you or you can
build it yourself
we built that we met we are building the
tooling to enable people to do that and
finally well tested oh my gosh we came
up with a Tet for all of our main core
services we had suite hundreds of unit
of hundreds of unit and integration
tests they run every time we build every
time we build an azure dev ops it's
running all of those tests it takes a
little while but at the end of the day I
can sleep on Fridays I can sleep in on
four I can sleep in on Saturday knowing
that that it's well tested and it's
gonna do it and that if we happen to
catch the random thing that isn't
covered by a test that's a bug great
we'll write tests for it to cover it we
can go back to sleep it's perfect
lessons learned from this rewrite don't
forget your roots right couple of things
to talk about here the business is more
important than the technology and what I
mean by that is that the business is
that knowing that visit people came to
us to solve their business problems
right the technology didn't matter to
them they just wanted to see the data
move appropriately and they wanted to
see their customers happy or they wanted
to be a happy customer so we were able
to do that we embraced we embrace
technology as much as we needed to but
we never forgot that we are mainly in
the business of solving integration
problems for the construction vertical
that's always served as well
this was our current roughly our current
Architecture from from we still had
customers on it right this third rewrite
we have customers on it but we still
have lots of customers on this and we
can't forget about them new who may be
cool and shiny but legacy still matters
because that's still where a large part
of our money's coming in that's fine
we'll take we take it for what it is
learn the lessons we're working on a
transition plan
it's never easy but we're working on it
so getting down to the nitty-gritty what
worked and what didn't
I'm not gonna bash monoliths I'm not one
of those people that said you have to
break everything out into micro services
if I went to my first company and said
hey you really need to break everything
out into micro services they'd probably
like look at me with the blame
they're like well why and I wouldn't be
able to come up with a good answer
the monolith the monolith model for our
old product worked until it didn't and
then we improved it and we've made it a
lot better so just know it's it's hard
it can be hard to recognize when that
when that shift needs to occur but it's
really valuable but don't I'm not here
to throw the baby out with the bathwater
mana lists are sometimes good just
depends on the business you're in then
and what you're building so the early
wins are really promising it's a very
easy and testable very testable
development model very much easier to
support especially from a data
perspective developers no longer need to
be the first person to look at the data
to see if it's broken it's much more fat
it's much faster and it's much easily
customizable there's a lot of early wins
that we sit that we've found as far as
dressing old pain points we've done a
huge we've moved forward a lot we're
still finding those dragons we're still
finding those bugs and guarantee it to
ask me next year when I'm here next year
ask me what they are going back to the
rewrites not only did we
so we've accomplished we've achieved
that we're still in the process of doing
it but we have we have really truly
taken something rewritten it three times
and we're making it even better and
we're gonna scale even better as a
result and as for me well this is where
I left off right last time and I can't
do it all right and you can't do it
forever you certainly can't do it all
forever because change is inevitable as
your company grows you will need to grow
too I read an article by this guy I
tweeted it out I highly recommend taking
it a read this guy's name Steve Blank
and he said that he worked at a company
where he was the VP of Marketing and he
was at the top of his game until the new
CEO came in and he said you're awesome
you've done an awesome job but I'm gonna
fire you because you're the wrong person
to take the company to the next step and
I gotta tell you that article trigger I
sent it immediately to my CEO it
triggered every one of my insecurities
like that I hope this doesn't become me
and he's like dude brother I hope it
doesn't become me either so really
really learn to recognize as your
company grows as your company changes
how will you change yourself or will you
change yourself is it better or is it
better for you to walk away only you can
know that read the article really
highly recommend it as for this I was
here sometimes I'm here and sometimes
when I need to get nitty-gritty
sometimes you just need to get stuff
done
everybody makes those sacrifices
sometimes so where am i at the point of
the rewrite as far as myself I don't
know I'm still working on it I like to
think I'm here but it's never that
simple
oh one last thing before I go
they've I'm sure they've announced the
day they will announce at some point two
days for NDC Oslo next year I'm hoping
not to be on the schedule with this talk
seven rewrites one one startup because
I'll probably out be out on the streets
of Oslo or somewhere they get from honey
because I'd certainly be out of a job
that's it that's all I have for you if
you have questions please come see me
upfront I'm here all the time here the
rest of the conference find me on
Twitter if you're not able to come up
enjoy the rest of your evening got a
boat cruise to catch thank you very much
[Applause]